ladies and gentlemen please stop
panicking about bitcoin's price falling
this is nothing that is abnormal yes
bitcoin is down 50 plus percent off of
the all-time high from november it hit
69 000
nice back in november and it has dropped
50 percent but that is not abnormal
compared to the historical price
drawdowns that we have seen yes this is
a volatile asset and so when we go ahead
and we look at all of these historical
corrections what you can see here is all
the way to the far left back in january
of 2012
there was a 42 percent drawdown then we
got a 56 percent drawdown in august of
2012. then we got an 82 drawdown in
2013. we got a 49 drawdown in 2013 again
in 2016 we got a 86.9
drawdown then we got a number of 30 and
40 percent drawdowns all the way through
2017 then of course the big bad bear
market showed up in 2018 83 drawdown
baby then in 2020 60 down 50 of that was
literally in one day
and of course now in last year of 2021
we had a 51.1 percent drawdown so last
year alone in 2021 there was a couple of
things we had over six different
drawdowns of 20
we had three or more drawdowns of 30
and we had a 50 drawdown in the last
four years there has been four separate
drawdowns of over 50
calm down stop panicking this is par for
the course when you have an asset that
goes up hundreds or thousands of percent
to the upside of course it is going to
have corrections along the way but even
if bitcoin which is drawn down 50 was to
go down another 50
which would mean 75
off of the top it still would not be
more than what we saw in 2016 in 2013 or
in 2018. now i personally don't think
that that's what we're gonna see but it
is important to keep that perspective if
we go back to last year during the
summer what we saw was there was a 95
day bear market not really a bear market
as a market correction is more likely
that 95 day period we saw a 51 percent
drop on a bitcoin's price so far as we
have bled off of those all-time highs at
69 000 back in november we're about 73
74 75 days into this current market
correction so if we were simply to
repeat last summer we got about another
20 days take a deep breath go grab a
glass of wine maybe a cigar and chill
the hell out
if we look off of those 2021 highs it's
not just bitcoin though there's tons of
assets tara luna down 49 bitcoin 50
binance bnb 51 ethereum 53 avalanche 64.
solana 66 cardano 70 xrp 72 shiba inu i
told y'all that was a [ __ ] coin down 76
and dogecoin which i also told you was a
[ __ ] coin down 84
now of course when there is a drawdown
in bitcoin's price everything else
follows bitcoin is the king bitcoin is
the blue chip and so naturally you
should expect this and then of course if
we look at the bitcoin correction our
friend charlie bolillo here absolutely
coming in hot with the stats what you
can see is that that bitcoin high of
about sixty nine thousand dollars all
the way down to about thirty three
thousand dollars fifty two percent
decline in order to return to a new
all-time high it's 109 upside let's see
when that happens after the markets have
bottomed in the past it has been
everything from eight days back in 2017
all the way up to
1181 days to return to a new all-time
high nobody knows what's gonna happen in
the future but what we do know is that
this is not the first time it's happened
again the last four years there has now
been four fifty percent corrections
chill out stop the madness john what do
you think
yeah i mean this is nothing new to
bitcoin in cryptocurrencies right they
are extremely volatile in the market
people are continuously getting
liquidated which is drawing the price
down even further but this is almost
what we should be expecting um when you
look at the looming fed rate hike when
you look at all other stocks are down
people don't like it because it starts
to mean that these
cryptos are correlated to the stock
market so when all the stocks and tech
stocks are getting drawn down so is
crypto which isn't really a good sign
because it's really looking at crypto as
a commodity and not the currency that a
lot of people want to view it as so we
just have to watch this coming forward i
expect this to be pretty similar going
forward um but hopefully we'll see
an uptrend later on this year joe yeah i
think uh it's it's interesting how
bitcoin has performed over the last few
weeks specifically what i'm more
interested about though is like what
happens from here the fed has uh
everyone is assuming they're going to
hike rates multiple times some people
are saying two some people are saying
four some people are even saying seven i
don't think anyone has any general idea
or specific idea but generally people
believe that they're gonna hike rates i
think what's interesting though is like
what do they do in the face of this
right tech stocks are shelling off
everything is selling off really uh
crypto's down a lot bitcoin is down a
lot you got pelotons down 85 percent uh
netflix went down 25 in one day the
other day right so like every risk asset
is selling off right now because of the
expectation that the fed is going to
come in and hike rates and that's what
happens when they hike rates so
ultimately it's going to be interesting
to see like how aggressive do they get
do they do it at all i don't know the
answer to that i think people still
expect that they're going to do this
regardless of kind of short-term pain in
the market but ultimately that's what's
going to start to drive uh uh these
things right because if you think about
inflation everyone wants inflation under
control seven percent it was a 40-year
high i think uh you know everyone from
elected officials to regular everyday
citizens want that under control so the
idea is that you raise rates but
ultimately the stock market plays a huge
role in that and if everyone starts
seeing their 401k uh get crushed their
stock portfolio get crushed the general
market get crushed i think that
narrative quickly can change so it'll be
interesting to see kind of how the fed
reacts to this because just the
insinuation that they're going to start
aggressively raising rates has obviously
had a material impact on the stock
market it'll be interesting to see if
that changes their viewpoint one way or
the other there's a entire thought
process that inflation ends up following
the conversation so people think
inflation is coming they start to move
capital based on uh inflation coming
right you try to front run the inflation
uh you start to increase your prices of
goods because you think inflation is
coming and so the more people think
inflation coming the more they act that
way the more they act that way the more
that they actually force the inflation
to actually show up right so
conversation or narrative can drive the
outcome
i think what the federal reserve's
trying to do here is the exact same in
the opposite direction as they're trying
to say hey the more that we talk about
raising rates the more that we talk
about uh kind of tightening and tapering
then the more people are going to act as
if we're doing it and therefore that
will help drive the impact on the market
that we want and they actually aren't
going to end up you know in some cases
we've seen uh public companies or bank
ceos say that they think there's gonna
be six or seven different interest rate
hikes in 2022 i don't think that's going
to happen i do think we will get some
interest rate hikes but i don't think
it's going to be anywhere near as severe
as kind of the doomsdayers are saying
right i think what is more likely is
that they're actually using the language
and their posturing to drive action that
action ends up leading to much more
obviously sell-offs etc but there's
absolute carnage in the market right now
but at the end of the day
it's still a good time in which you have
to be as an investor to joe's point
if you look backwards if you try to
drive down the street looking in the
rear view mirror it's going to be real
hard to stay on the road if you look
forwards it's much easier obviously to
stay on the road and as an investor
that's your whole job right charlie
munger warren buffett the number one
rule in investing is don't be stupid
basically just avoid stupidity and if
that is the key if it's simply just stay
on the road make sure you don't get
blown up don't have high leverage don't
lose all your money don't nest
unnecessarily interrupt compounding all
these timeless investing principles stay
on the road look through the windshield
not through the rear view mirror when
you look through the rear view mirror
backwards you're making stupid decisions
i dare and actually no i'm not going to
say that but please don't let anyone go
try to drive by looking in the rearview
mirror as they drive down the street but
you get the point